c'est non
les chroniques de la haine ordinaire
[Musique]
triste époque
sale temps pour le baisemain ya du
laisser-aller dans la pratique du savoir
vivre
depuis qu'on baise avant de se dire
bonjour les bonnes manières ont pris
comme un coup de vieux
il n'y a plus de vrais jeunes filles nos
demoiselles ne font plus de révérence
qu'a connue dans la tente de quelques
hommages postérieurs
il n'y a plus de job semaine
gentlemen examen anouk and played by
people who does not
the man c'est quelqu'un qui sait jouer
de la cornemuse et qui nous rejoue pas
ces trois qu'il dit c'est un dicton
anglais complètement suranné
malheureusement les jantes le mène
aujourd'hui ils ne savent pas jouer de
la guitare électrique et il en joue
[Musique]
on sait plus tenir dans les soirées
mondaines de mon temps on n'aurait
jamais osé arrivée à un dîner les mains
vides je me rappelle les petits soupers
chez le duc et la duchesse de windsor à
boulogne où j'avais mes entrées dans les
années 70
une commune admiration pour l'oeuvre
inachevée du chancelier hitler et pour
les pages couleurs deux jours de france
nous avait rapproché
et bien j'arrive à chaque fois
avec comme on dit un petit quelque chose
je connaissais les goûts de la duchesse
je savais que rien ne pouvait lui faire
plus plaisir qu'un peu d'argent
et puis c'était original au lieu de me
pointer avec une botte d'anémone ou une
bouteille de mousseux
j'attendais qu'il ouvrit la porte et
croyez moi quand je lui tendais mais
trois billet de 50 francs on lui [ __ ]
la main je faisais mon petit effet aux
pierres grand fou grand fou qu'est ce
que vous m'apportez la mine audetel en
2d gracieusement ses fans ont pour faire
envoler ses pellicules
150 fier c'est trop il ne fallait pas et
doit elle ou être créée et elle a
l'intention du vieil abdiqué gonflable
qui se joue qui se biodégrader sur un
grabat doré el oued el oued regardez ce
que pierre nous a apporté
et lui
c'est trop il ne fallait pas s'écriait
le vieillard alors bien sûr par
délicatesse pour ne pas les blesser je
reprenais 50 francs
mais ce sont des coutumes qui se perdent
comme tant d'autres hélas
avez vous remarqué je m'adresse ici où
plus de 40 ans je conseille aux plus
jeunes d'aller finir de ceux des
pustules et les comédons en écoutant le
groupe indochine sur europe 1
avez vous remarqué combien les gens sont
mal habile et emprunté de nos jours face
aux rituels pourtant simplissime qui
consiste à présenter ses amis les uns
aux autres au début d'une soirée
naguère l'on disait par exemple monsieur
le grand rabbin permettez moi de vous
présenter monsieur jean marie
c'est un exemple idiot ouf monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur permettez moi de
vous présenter monsieur mehmedi rideaux
fermés mais guérineau permettez moi de
vous présenter monsieur le médiateur
c'est tout mais c'était simple parfois
on précisait discrètement la fonction
des invités que l'on présentait afin
bien sûr de permettre aux gens de se
reconnaître des affinités d'engager un
si quelquefois de passionnants débats
cher monsieur jacob delafon permettez
moi de vous présenter et monsieur michel
coluche des restaurants du coeur cher
monsieur michel coluche permettez moi de
vous présenter monsieur jacob delafon
des cabinets du
q7
sans jouer à proprement parler les
entremetteuses il n'était pas rare
qu'une maîtresse de maison
particulièrement intuitive fut à
l'origine de quelques idylle dont elle
savait encourager l'éclosion par de
subtiles allusions au moment de
présenter l'un à l'autre deux jeunes
gens paralysé de timidité qui ne se
fussent jamais risquer à s'avouer leurs
tendres penchant
lutte non je suis particulièrement
heureuse de vous présenter isabelle
clarisse du gué de la gitonnière
ancien pensionnaire des soeurs de
chavagne à nantes qui vient d'obtenir le
prix ludmilla sherin a pour son grand
écart dans le final du lac des cygnes
sur gazon
isabelle clarisse je vous présente le
sous lieutenant bernard henri bilbocks
un qui aime bien être en dessous
hélas chair s'invite tout cela c'est le
passé nos us et coutumes ne sont plus de
mise la bienséance ne veulent guère plus
aucun projet challenger les jeunes dans
leur boom ce salut pour la première fois
avec une consternante désinvolture
incapable kapinga pina kpatcha pas une
pipe tout fout l'camp
quant à ces féroces soldats je le dis
c'est pas pour gâtés ils font rien qu'à
venir dans nos camps
[Musique]
fait peu non